you know like the fact that I was
basically my character is sexually
harassed through the whole thing and
then I go for him at the end they did
not get that at all oh that's so
interesting and I was really happy that
they didn't like that that that was not
a turn on for my daughter and I said
well yeah back when I was making those
movies that was a turn on for like if
anybody treated you badly that's the one
that you
wanted the less you want me I want you
yeah but but having said that there is
still so much that I love in the movie
the fact that it it really breaks down
these characters and says that there's
this something that we all have in
common and that we're all feeling the
same thing no matter what we look like
and what our social stratum is and that
kids have a voice and your voice is
important and it's important to speak up
so I mean all of those to me um make the
film really meaningful